all right staying in flow from our
previous episode let's talk about this
in the deeper cut so we were talking
about heaviness but the thing I realized
that we start to talk about the the
challenges we were having especially
like navigating social media and like a
growing practice community but I
realized that there was a little anger
in me like on that like there are there
are things that are deeply meaningful to
me that and I'm like focused on that
maybe that was like some of the problem
in the first place
and yeah this this year has been there's
been a lot more happening for me than
that I mean the the biggest event in my
life was you know my mother got really
sick very sick and she passed away a few
months ago so yeah as well as navigating
you know with things that happen in our
business this was like a real yeah this
was a real journey or saw something very
different in a way up and actually more
normal like something maybe we're all
going to face at some point
so I don't know this is a way I wanted
to I almost talked about it in our first
interview but I actually didn't know
that you had such a like willingness to
to explore everything so yeah when I
shared it with you it was called to see
you like yeah no I'm I would love to
explore that
one of the things that this brings up is
this idea of impermanence and that
we are temporary and that
we have grandparents and parents that
have
either pasture will be passing soon and
we will be passing soon and so this this
is what it calls up for me
so to contemplate death and to hear
about it from your perspective going
through this really tough year that you
went through with growing where you're
building while also having what happened
with your mother
yeah what was what was this how did it
how did it set in for you well that I I
was very blessed with a incredibly
loving mother and telogen mother as well
and so it was obviously huge to hear
that she was so sick and and my family
absolutely adores her as well so it was
like devastating for them and the the
the big thing like being so committed to
these practices of presence and
surrender and it was late devastating
and I cried deeply and I've like met
anguish in me but at the same time there
was a trust that also I was going to be
shown by life there's something I can
imagine which ended up being true so
even though it was kind of it was a
tragedy and like an unexpected like she
was quite a healthy 61 year old
there was yeah there was also this like
I don't know if readiness is the right
waiver almost like I'd prepared to to
kind of meet that whatever that was
going to be and I've had my stepfather
died when I was young and what it's like
different kind of experience they know
one I think I understand why people have
such difficulty grieving because that
experience was totally different
it was slate I can remember how I hadn't
processed it four years after and being
in shock for years without realizing it
just being a young young man at the time
no I was a boy at the time 10 but this
was a totally different experience
your mother was 61
yeah how's it to talk about here with us
and what camera did one of the things
that comes up is actually my family like
care about them deeply and like part of
me is like tracking like if they were
listening and may like honoring them and
like honoring my mom yeah more like I
don't want to talk in any kind of way
that like oh yeah this was like a
transformational experience and it's so
wonderful I feel a sensitivity and the
late in all my years late have done a
lot of exploring transformation and
groups and with people and friends and
I've seen wonderful things but actually
wanted like this thing amazed me was
like how we as a family grew together in
this process it was my mind boggling
actually you couldn't imagine such
transformation and but lay in a subtle
way as well but just the love we
experienced together and coming together
the the converse the conversations that
we we had to have but we really did have
it's really something else
I can feel the love tenderness now
and I feel the beauty being able to find
something that is so powerful for you
and your family in such a difficult
circumstance
and I feels really beautiful and they're
such nice humbling experiences like I
didn't know the subtle ways that I like
expected different
different people have met different
people different family members my
brother's my stepfather even my mother
did subtle ways I was like I don't know
comparing myself or like wanting to be
seen and these little subtle ways and
something happened where it just that
just got cut through and like my family
was seeing me anyway like the places I
was trying to be seen were actually more
of getting in the way of what was
already beautiful and very humbling to
see where I was actually even in my like
a tenth to like be present or to like be
accepting of what was happening even in
that sometimes I found the subtle ways I
was trying to actually teach it or and
and then also my own innocence in that
like I was trying to navigate something
very painful and I was very scared but
slowly through the process it was like I
was being shown like a new level of
letting go like what it means to really
like honor someone where they are and I
don't know if how you know maybe there's
deeper I can learn this but certainly
gave me a lot of lessons in that
yeah are you touch yeah I am and I want
to ask a question that can sometimes be
difficult to answer do you feel like you
were able to connect with your mom at a
deep enough degree prior to her passing
that you were able to sort of
that we would you say that there was
enough of the wisdom this
transgenerational wisdom that was passed
on and knowledge I was passed on from
mom to son prior to the passing yeah
yeah and now you really touch me say
it's it was an incredible process like
in the beginning late there was like you
know the realization of the finality
that was possible
like I knew a year and a half they
before that it was very serious and then
suddenly I'm like oh I I want to have as
much connection I I don't want to waste
any moment and like got very like and
and part of that was true like and now
and was good like I became very
motivated without any effort of course
to be in connection with my mum more and
to visit more and to like you know just
listen to her more but I was also scared
that what if we didn't really connect
what and might my mum had it has a
different way to me like no she's not
used to this you know transformational
culture and you know this so it was
scary because I was like so yearning to
be with her and at the same time I did
the worst thing ever was to push her in
too late you know past her comfort zone
because of my need and at the same time
knowing that like you know we're mother
and son so we have all our kind of
complex no dynamics so it was like so
intense
just noticing that your like it seems
close to tears or can you say more about
what's happening as you you shall talk
about that tender navigation yeah that's
the word word navigation yeah
because mom and son are on different
world views and there's a like you said
a need for you to want to connect and to
dive deep into her worldview in her life
and all this type of stuff but she's
also at a very tender place in her
passing time to pass and so this is like
a very crazy time for how does one how
do you interplay that
yeah
and it it there was really different
transition points late looking back I'm
really grateful for the question I did
there was a real like I was really
exploring this as well like having like
you know friends like this and even like
while I was leading events because of
the way we structure the practice we we
don't lead like from a place that we've
you know spiritually realized everything
so we're just leading others we lead
from our authenticity which means taking
responsibility as a leader but also
being human so I was like deeply
processing the grief in the groups with
my friends and like and our culture
we've built you know as friends is that
they were always there for me so I had a
lot of deep crying but there was still
that longing with my mother but also the
you know wanting to honor where she is
but I had this moment where
like I went on a deep journey late
especially him I did some trauma
development training which gave me at
another kind of place to let go deeper
into this but what I discovered there's
a place in me when I go really deep
where I get frozen people might relate
to that way like I just get like very
still sometimes I could used to mistake
it as a kind of meditative state which
in one sense is but in another sense
it's also like the kind of trauma
reaction or like another system responds
to fear so I get really frozen and if
I'm really trusting the connection and I
start to really ache but I got mat in
this aching and then suddenly like I
just got a so what are you a king for
and it never occurred to me in this deep
space that the aching was telling me
something I just thought it's the pain I
had to endure to for transformation but
obviously if I was in when I became
intimate with the pain that it was
anguish I was like oh I'm longing for
touch
but not any normal touch and then I just
invite I got it was it was a hard
navigation because I would like pop out
and late but then the court brought say
who do want to be touched by and then it
like hit me like on my mother
mmm-hmm no one no one touch me like she
did so sweet and they so trusted her
like so trusted her with her boundaries
and so it was like oh my god I didn't
know that deep longing for that and the
sweetness I felt having accessed that it
was so sweet
yes and it it was late that was like we
spoke about in the previous talk like
when you've got this like layers in you
that you don't realize you just act
regardless so like when I felt frozen or
like aching I'd be like ah I'm not
feeling well or I'm like you know try
and find some way to wake myself up but
actually what was happening was the deep
intelligence in me was like saying like
oh like if you listen there's something
you really need and it's really hard for
you to know what you need and I'll guide
you and what it guided me to was my
longing from or the sweetness of like
the love I would receive from my mum and
straightaway it was like I could
remember it as if it was like the most
obvious thing like I mean remember being
a boy and you got this woman and she's
so wonderful and she looks after you and
sheep this cares for you all the time
it's like like that's like a miracle and
it feels amazing I used to work with
children and it reminded me of this as
well and I use in sports and one time I
asked this boy who I really liked he's a
really cool kid he would just be honest
I say who's the person you most like to
hang out
with and he went and any smile he's like
yes and so remembering that sweetness so
the next time I was my mother I didn't
have this thing of like I need to be
able to do something so we can connect
mmm I was like the sweetness already is
almost unbearable oh wow and the
vulnerability for me to show that it's
in me it's not like I need to do
something and show her transformational
processes or all that interesting
suddenly it was like and and then we had
a conversation and I just shared with
her like I want to tell you something
and it's it's not easy for me to share
cuz it gets scared that like I don't
want to be too much for you and she's
and then she's obviously sweet and as
that I don't know don't worry and then I
was just like moment the thing I love
more than anything is like just time
when I can be with you just me and you
but I can't say it like this I was like
crying I said and she was just like wow
yeah but but as soon as I said that and
it the relief of like this whole thing
that like oh we need to have this like
conversation before we part forever
yeah suddenly was like relax like I
could just tell my mom how sweet it
feels to be with her
to have been given this gift to lift
this life with her like that we had this
journey together like what like what a
miracle and yeah
yeah so that that's how that changed
Oh
for those that are blessed to have that
beautiful relationship with their mother
from the time that they're born because
some of us are missing that basic
nutrient in the roots of love and
compassion from our parents
and altar food water all that type of
stuff and it makes total sense to me why
people are like trying to compensate and
doing other kind of strange things it
seems like to content because the
sweetness is like it's it's like inside
nectar yeah yeah humming into your body
like ice why we take ecstasy because
it's like it feels amazing toughs things
moving like inside but when it's just
the love you have this just yeah
damn and this is why it is
it's what's this so there's so much one
of the interesting things is that we
have a friend that continues to say oh
let's program mom into AI and I'm like
wow
interesting how can we do that it sounds
great potentially nice love
anti-nationalist as you said this nectar
it's something really interesting
happening now because like when you talk
when you were talking about it I was
like I want to cry you're tearing up a
little we're like feeling that the kind
of grief but now I feel like like that
you talking about the sweetness acai so
almost happy even though we were talking
about yeah your your mom passing like
there's a feel of shared resonance of
like some sort of joy coming out don't
know if it changes it me saying it I
felt by which was the you know time yeah
that was and and just like the it's a it
so there's mom for you
yeah in Austin Texas and healthy yeah I
mean every relationships got its quirks
for sure the cheese house in but yeah
yeah likewise
yeah healthy mom with quirks
yeah and Sioux Falls South Dakota just
very
the very yeah holy cow just a limited
amount of time the clock's ticking the
clock's ticking how much time do you
have left with your loved ones the
clock's ticking
yeah I feel so lucky like my mom I
travel a lot for work and she will offer
him like take me to the airport or pick
me up and it's so sweet this like just
uninterrupted time yeah traffic and it's
like 45 minutes or an hour or like just
to catch up and talk and yeah yeah yes
yeah yeah yeah with you both recently
and I could see at the end as I oh yeah
can feel your mum's like willingness to
take you to the airport because she just
so loves the time with you yeah yeah now
I'll be I'm happy to take a you know
ride chair or whatever and but she like
really looks forward to a 92 it's quite
cool there on the deeper cat we start
talking about how much we love a surreal
deeper kind I also feel will use the
next thing it's like well I feel a
little shy cuz now my girlfriend's
starting to pick me up at the airport
actually this hits on a really
interesting point about how what is it
with when a baby is able to get the moms
love
to its wildest degrees of compassion and
love and just care that and like you
said no one touched me like my mom did
you know no one talks with the same
degree of unconditional love as a mom so
where does that get the biological clock
right these are ticking ticking ticking
all of a sudden gone then what
where does unconditional love when you
do the clock ticking I feel angry
it might make you even more if I said
that you might only have like 3,000 days
left with your mom
that feels like a lot of days but I mean
but if you're only spending one day or
10 days with them a year that's 300 days
left
or even just a hundred days left with
them once what's the anger no I don't
feel it now you have to do oh yeah it's
just like just the amount of days if you
live until you're about 82 or so you'll
have about 30,000 days to live and out
of those 30,000 days you're gonna spend
about a third of them asleep I want to
feel the anger more and I think it's
connected to like some something some
energy that I think you're embodying
when you do this like it feels more real
to me than the numbers of the days
Oh interesting oh cool okay okay so so
then like it when you do yeah it's like
like I know it's not you but I think
it's like I'm almost like I'm like don't
[ __ ] take don't do that yeah yeah
that's interesting okay so the because
I've been kind of trying to maybe in
augment people's perspective with saying
that you'll only get 30,000 days to live
but it's not working as well apparently
as when I'm like these are the moments
that are passing and every moment that's
passing that we're not acting with our
mother or with our girlfriend there's
something oh yeah totally the this is
the this is the clock for you know build
something you know build build build
into the world build build build into
the world the hierarchy the hierarchy
run run sprint upward sprint upward
execute build right and then at the same
yeah you're like you I get that away
from me right but at the same time then
you have to do things like mom like
girlfriend like nature like meditation
anyway this conversation
just got transitioned to hierarchies and
time and that's slightly different than
where we were at a little moment ago
unless unless we we stay with like you
and like your experience of this cuz it
seems like you like you're something
like super meaningful to you about this
you're like yeah there is and it's a
mission you're like I want to I want
people to know there's 30,000 days thing
like yeah it's part of what like you're
trying to do even with this show wake
wake up yeah what is yeah maybe maybe
that's maybe that is wake up this is
time and I wonder if it's best because
there's like a power in that and like
but I wonder we'll say it's like the
pain of regret they don't create the
pain of regret try think that as well
there's so many reasons why we just
co-created how this is powerful because
I think not only is at the moments that
are going by but it's the sound it
activates a new thing when I just when
when you just say every second is going
by there's like it doesn't resonate with
you as much as when someone's there's
something about it being a noise to that
is more awakening I think but but yeah
but I think like what I imagine you like
being you like walking around or doing
this to do like wanting people to like
like there's something where I imagine
like you almost like defending the
preciousness of life you're like yes hey
[ __ ] yes yeah yes yeah you know
this like this this moment right now yes
matters a lot yes every one of these
matters a lot and so when another one of
these you know the same person that I
mentioned earlier again came up with
this Junoon opportunity
be city we have so many opportunities
that are constantly coming at us for
engaging with people socially for this
or in a project for that it's just
endless it's like a buffet of
opportunities and we have obesity with
it to such a degree that we're not
actually able to more easily potentially
identify what is our true
what should we truly be doing with this
precious time that we have and then
interestingly enough things get weighed
weighted differently when you have a mom
that gets sick all of a sudden this
becomes way more heavily in the
direction of mum than it was before you
can see it going time goes closer to mum
whereas before when mom's healthy it's
like well I can work and I can play and
I go to mum for bed and then I go back
to work and stuff but then when a family
member falls sick holy crap are we yeah
yeah well one of the first things I met
was the feeling the pain of the time I
wasted or I just I got all the memories
of like being on the phone with mum and
late I'm late on the internet at the
same time
that was painful dear and and so was
like man and then how that turned into
late every phone call I had with her was
like like any minute I could have with
her was and as she got sicker she
obviously could speak for less time so
you know I wanted to be careful with her
time and yet I so wanted to be with her
and like every time she just stayed
saying like darling to me which I don't
think she used to say but she just
started saying that and those moments
were late
yeah yeah
so what it what a change in time and
though this is gonna sound very AI but
to be able to capture our loved ones
facial expressions voice nuanced
inflection right all this type of stuff
and package it into something that could
maybe at a later time have it's this
form of digital awareness in space with
us in the future past their time with us
is something that people are like or
have been exploring with the last ten
years and it's capturing like mine files
and stuff and yeah
which these words like darling to like
be able to hear that at a later time
past their death to some people it's
like [ __ ] weird and they don't want
that but to other people it's like man I
would hear my mom say these things these
pet names and whatnot these loving kind
phrases
yeah I would hear them forever if I
could would you
I'm not sure I'm I'm fascinated like
what is gonna happen as sweet AI evolves
and like these things are possible
sometimes you think it's creepy and
weird and then as it evolves it actually
is okay or something but yeah but I I
don't get tracted to it now like I lay
in my process like actually going deeper
into the grief and the love I feel
brings the memory and the sense of
connection with my mother stronger than
like collecting stuff and yeah yeah say
you had two great examples of when
you're on the phone in the past you like
looking back and being like wow we're
like maybe that car ride where from back
from the airport where the conversation
just kind of derailed into something
that maybe wasn't as productive because
maybe I had made some sort of a mistake
in the way that I was speaking and I
didn't though it's almost as the older
I'd be coming the older my mother has
become the more I've become aware of
just how much like my gratitude per
minute it has increased significantly
with my mom which is for those that are
blessed to have mom I'm still a little
stuck on this but like to two things the
first is like there's something about
like counting the moments that doesn't
actually feel true to me like when I
look at my experience like my actual
subjective experience of time is pretty
like look I I don't
hmm I mean and it reminds me of even
like the mathematical concept of like
there's the infinity that you can like
keep counting and that that's like in
some systems like that's the first
infinity but like because
you could take like between any two
points you could like subdivide it an
infinite number of times and then
subdivide that in it there's an infinite
infinities within it so it's actually
infinitely bigger and I'm like so if
this is your birth and this is your
death or this is like when you get to
know your mom this is when you don't
like it matters like how you preside do
you think you have a set number of
moments like a number line or like or is
there kind of an infinite like depth
that you can go into in in-between that
that feels yeah
my phenomenological experience
yeah it's a cool way to think of time
and and then it's like yeah this is this
drive for more time or more whatever
it's like it starts to make a lot less
sense than like a a drive to be more
with the like fullness of here which I
know you're fully but like on board with
there's several things there yeah well
yeah
so first is yes there's the infinite
amount of points from zero to one okay
and then there's the yes technically
then you've we could be spending an
infinite amount of time together from
now until every moment that goes by
together but there's I think something
and then there's also the point of like
there is no past present and future that
all time happens at once so there's also
that perspective that all time is
happening at once okay alright so now
that we let's put ourselves back in the
3d reality that we live reside in where
we do have a biological clock
where we do have a limitation it's
fantastic to philosophize about
pre-birth post-death all that is we're
all one time is all that is these are
fantastic things to philosophize about I
love it too and I'm all about that all
is one and then I've no no kazoos oh no
like no worries about the hierarchy and
climbing it and mom and like mom passing
at some point and no worries about time
to spend in a relationship and having
kids no worries but then there's like in
another force that comes in and that
force is like no really like how are you
passing your time yeah what is that
forcing you that's a that's like because
like the whole idea of just being all
whatever like flowy flowy cosmic flow
but sensing like in in your world it's
like oneness is like different from the
kind of flow of life and it's like
that's great okay so like like ladi Dadi
die when your hair in oneness and then
here it's like you're driven and you
yeah yeah you're like what this doesn't
include the kiss thing yeah my
experience of oneness
yeah person it doesn't Clint okay here's
the thing it does include right let's
sit let's put let's put it on the table
like we said at the beginning that it
does include okay I'm not convinced okay
fine I think I can explain why maybe I
can explain why maybe I can't right
looks like you're feeling it right now I
am feeling it I'm totally feeling it
like I'm feeling the surrender to to the
oneness but then you've got this March
cuz you've got to like switch the camera
with your right hand you're like yeah
you're like the march of time like if I
don't switch this camera people are
gonna get bored and well I just have to
keep the conversation you know flowing
to where it's going with the camera
shots but but that's this isn't even as
important I would say I mean the kind of
what we're talking about is very
important I'm gonna try and defend this
point okay yeah it's an interesting
point to try and defend it's not an
argument against oneness and it's almost
like and there is there's an aspect to
oneness which is the biological clock in
the 3d reality okay so it's let's say
it's embedded within oneness and then
within this embedded biological clock
and the oneness is you choosing moment
to moment you're collapsing the
trajectory of your life with your
choices and you're going down different
paths
so when you have the choice to do
something like start a business or write
a poem or marry that woman or go pass
some time with your mom or travel
somewhere or not right burger or salad
even like just down to the most mundane
more decisions or not you work making
decisions in the oneness of the
biological time encapsulated framework
of decision making and there's something
deeply mysterious and this right yeah
there's something that matters to me a
lot what yeah what's the energy like no
yeah it's like the most serious thing on
the planet is that what I just described
one of the most serious things on the
planet love and consciousness right are
like two of the most serious things on
the planet and then like time
and and I think what I'm wondering is
like so when I feel my version of this I
wonder how similar this year's like when
you talk about like collapsing
possibilities first I feel fear I almost
get like a panic or a terror and and
then it's very hard for me to think
which is kind of weird cuz now I I'm in
it and I can't think of the other thing
I was gonna say and I could feel it
right now it's like oh my god like this
I might run out well maybe it's less of
I might run out and it's more that that
you get to pick which life trajectory
you can bark on and it's important to
make decisions that if you have the
opportunity to do something like get a
mentor like a one-on-one tutor from
someone that is the you guys were just
talking about in the last conversation
you leveled up surrounded yourself with
people that humbled you right and then
all of a sudden you've exploded your
growth but that's because you were able
to identify that you leveled up you
needed new people you needed to learn
from them you need to humble yourself
right these are all things that you need
to do each one of those decisions led
you to more opportunities more open
doors and so that's why every single one
of these decisions especially something
like identifying this mentor that can
then help you with opening doors and
understanding yourself better and stuff
welljust is such an important thing in
this 3d biologically constrained time
world is that you can potentially make
better decisions that will actualize
yourself at greater extents yeah that's
the just hit me again like the 3d time
bound world I'm like I feel this like
crazy alive like nervous belly and and
what it touches me into is this like
deep sense of inadequacy
I'm like oh my oh my god like damn
30,000 days or whatever it is I'm like
there's no way I can actualize or
accomplish or like even if I feel love
like there's no acting love to these I
can't show the amount of love in my
heart and and it's like almost to the
point of shame how inadequate I feel
what's it like sharing that now
my I'm tight my whole body is tight
especially like my hips and
yeah it's like I I was in it inside had
to make I had to make a point
it's like that kind of energy like and
now like where the [ __ ] am i yeah they
seemed there was a drive to were only
inadequacy or they'd be honest about the
impact and now something shifted
was yeah it's like I wanted to I wanted
to like show the impact of that of Leia
Hall inhabiting that view and then it
just got me don't that make sense what's
happening yeah did it resonate that
impact yeah yeah I feel it a lot too I
think that's the way I'm like looking to
like meat meat you feel you and then I'm
like why am I trying to do that yeah
there's a lot of the feeling of well
what do I do with this where does this
go where do I direct it to maximize my
potential yes
it seems it comes out like
and you create stuff and that you want
to tell people right
the hook look what's happening and you
can like support yourself look that
there are things you can do and they
make a big difference and that sounds
right
and we DEP we've definitely been doing
that and I you know have that drive I
also find out feel relaxed I don't know
that's the oneness the city humanity
that's the chill which is which the
biological clock has just embedded
within that so it's a state of unity and
oneness and that state that we can
always tap into
yet embedded within that is this 3d a
reality of economic political and social
machinery that we embed ourselves in and
need to make decisions in with this
biological clock that then impact the
way that we live the rest of our lives
it gives me a bit of a handle on the
anger and I need y'all's help with this
but it's like
I feel like I feel a sort of pressure
from society or economy or whatever and
it's like I'm not in control of that
pressure and I think the pressure is to
like is is to somehow forget the oneness
mm-hmm and and because I like don't have
a mouth quite like right with me or
something in that I like blame the
pressure I can Peck I can't even quite
get out of the blame as I'm trying to
invite you all into this experience with
me set
yeah it I think it was what's happening
in me Asay realizing oneness it's like
not being a simple thing or and I don't
even know if I could say I have like
realize the depth of what that means
silly quite so they're ever in
kindergarten yeah so they say
one way that yeah that it doesn't quite
make sense that divide
yeah it's like it's like somewhere I
have some intuition that I've made a
choice to like
consent to the the other world yes
and then I I resent I forget that I made
that choice or can't handle it and so
that I would like project it out and
then resent the world for like having
done it to me to put this that we're
born into the 3d reality and the 3d
reality has the social economic and
political machinery embedded within it
and the only people right now that
pretty much are able to not participate
out of all eight billion humans are like
the Sentinelese Islanders that have
never left their Island and they're
never been contacted by the human
species so they're literally they're out
the exit door of the hierarchy and of
the social economic political machinery
but they're not even quite fully out the
exit door because they still have to
deal with like anthropogenic climate
change human caused climate change they
love to deal with helicopters and
airplanes and they're like you know what
is this what's the you know what so so
these are the sort of like you how do
you get yourself potentially out of your
birthed into the Monopoly board
hierarchy where you have to earn pay as
you go earn pay as you go and like what
do you do to to be like no I don't want
to play this game
I didn't where did I sign up for this
was did I sign up for this pre birth as
I came from wherever into this did I
sign for it but just that something
changed to me this time listening to you
like fill my heart more and realize that
just previously I was resisting a little
bit you're like like energy of
but this time I actually heard the care
and the concern in it mmm and like the
acknowledgement of like now I'm seeing
this like huge huge like organism that
is the macro and yet just seeing how
you're late look in the face of like
being honest and like real about the
challenges we face being like a part of
this like oh yawns please help yourself
at night and I'm here that's what I want
to serve I want to serve you navigating
that yeah yeah yeah it's good way to put
it I want to serve you navigating the
complex world and reality that we're all
partaking in mm-hmm and do you have any
resentment - I have resentment yeah
towards what towards this hierarchy that
were born into yeah as part of this game
it's part of the the game that we
entered into this round and how do you
relate to that being like born into this
game it's like a challenge that the
you're born into the game so that you
can can you when you're born into the
game can you understand the the code the
source code of the game so you learn the
source code of the game then you try and
make analogies and metaphors to get
other people to understand the source
code of the game then you help inspire
and engage other people and yourself to
write new code that obsoletes the old
code and makes a new playground that is
even better than the old one well so
when I hear that it's like
yeah I just want to acknowledge like the
passion in that as well there's a lot of
- yeah and then like I imagine like
watching your movie and it's like like
you've like changed the script of like
the matrix because you're like you've
like look I can like decode it so you've
let stop the bullets and then you've
like you've gone to the architect and
you're like get out of that seat
[ __ ] be a bike for a coveted -
DK yeah oh that's so great love you guys
thanks for thing like love you guys -
this has been so fun
i can'twe we started on your crazy story
with your mother and we ended on we're
always somehow end on updating the code
oh it's like such a frequent thing with
me do you have a little longer - yeah we
have time yeah just I just want to share
like I think my path or my matrix
trilogies like a little different just I
think the more I've like especially like
working with people and like being with
them and just like trying to see each
layer as it is the best I can and
failing sometimes and then learning and
trying to be and just like to see how
like each layer of them she has like
this gift and intelligence and then I
feel loved if I let him see that and
they usually feel seen so there's this
process I actually started to see that
transferring like onto the organism of
culture and
on bond too late the economic structure
and and just started to sense like well
there is a lot of pain and that it's
hard to be part of this like this life
experience but there's like an inherent
intelligence to it all that's mind
blowing you who like the fact that like
we were monkeys and like climbing trees
and the eating stuff if we could at
night and then this thing happened and
we started like becoming self conscious
as far as I can see and then not sure
after here we are in a metropolis or
whatever yeah connected to the whole
world was something in our pocket it's
like crazy innovation yes and like the
love in that and the intelligence is
unbelievable but if you just talk to an
AI person and like talk about like
trying to get like a robot to perceive
objects you're talking about a
complexity that's like you know only the
most brilliant people can like deal with
and like life has solved that in an
unbelievable way yeah but who took
billions of years beer and then that's
the same intelligence that created the
economic system yeah
and that's the same intelligence that's
helping us like speak this language that
came through a culture that learnt to
develop it yeah so there's there's
experience I have it's it's like falling
in love with the substructure of reality
that creates culture and
capitalism and all that but not not then
to be like oh great sort of love
interesting so it's the being in love
with the this is what we Aeros yeah eros
but also can you believe that anything
exactly yeah yeah as falling in love
with at the same time at the same time
they in in the love like that created me
and my personality and like what I care
about like in a way I'm like not
responsible for that in one in the
oneness you could say like that's all
being created through me but I still
experience it as me and me cares about
the economic system evolving the me
cares about people not being seen and
being treated not compassionately or
like in any way I can support like well
the natural calling for me to create and
support the healthy evolution of this
organism that's life that needs to be
taken seriously I think it's a mistake
to be like oh we're wine and we let's
trust everything it's all evolving it's
all intelligence and then so I just sit
back why would you do that totally that
what what I take in the game is your
puzzle piece of exact code and being the
players role yeah and life tells us well
in my experience life tells us that's
right because when I do that when I
really aligned to I care about
I feel like much better it's a like it's
like life lets me know that I'm like
aligning to something it cares about you
and to circle it all the way back around
to the previous conversation I don't
think you actually like this I think I
actually agree with what Sean saying but
I don't think one has to to like you can
almost run the experiment to like let me
let me try out for
or whatever like as if life actually has
is aiming towards some good end and like
once you do that then something really
terrible or difficult happens and if
you're like well life is aiming towards
something good than this then the only
way the best way to interpret this
adversity is that it says some challenge
for me to grow you need and then when
you think of it that way you actually
then grow from it so it's kind of a
self-fulfilling prophecy in the best
sense and then your life ends up better
so adversity becomes a lesson and life
becomes good because you held it that
way and it kind of proves itself to be
true in the experience of living a
better life
Flores I think right now he's a big
synthesis happening it's really nice
you and I can say that when at the heart
of our work we've the thing we kept
coming back to was surrender hmm and
often people think like surrender what
the hell like that's like like putting
up a white flag and saying like I submit
to a horrible force so it's like no it's
not not actually what it's really
pointing to it's like the thing I keep
discovering it's like if we really look
at life and reality we really feel it do
we trust and align with it
or do we say no it's not right life's
wrong in some way I need to control it
or be resentful for like what it's given
me and then be in a fight around what's
happening or like no I'm going too
deeply a lie deeper sense of truth I can
and then act from there be a vehicle for
that
that
essence we discover mhm yeah and that's
that how we we're navigating practice
and so then to bring that kind of macro
view into more micro into the
relationship and this is straight from
the our like advanced training just this
top-secret just for simulation oh oh
shout out I love it do it
it's not that secret but that sense of
like how do you practice that what Sean
just said like in in a moment in a
relationship and it's it's to give a
like in any moment no matter what's
happening to give a yes to it and to and
to work with it as a way of like
revealing more depth or intimacy then
that might include my desire to give and
no you button so it's like if I'm with
you and I and I'm like oh it seems like
you know you're you really enjoying this
conversation and then you say like no
actually I'm on my hating it I wish it
was somewhere else
one option is on my own no I got it
wrong and like we're now we're
disconnected but another is like oh
that's cool like Alan like and it's just
updated me and giving me like a better
sense of where he's at and where we're
at you know and like there's enough
intimacy between us that he can like
share something that might put us at
odds are in disagreement or intention
yep and so that's just look at those
little microcosms of like in in any
given moment where you notice a kind of
resistance to what's happening and and
like yeah maybe maybe you have to accept
that resistance and a kind of metal
level but usually it's that you can just
come in and be like I wonder if I could
soften just a little bit to say more but
yes to what's here even when that's a
very difficult painful thing like saying
yes to like my mom dying
and and how hard it is to be with that
yeah
these these these tiniest little changes
that we have in our these relationships
is critical how we view the situation
and so for me that situation would be
total learning experience but I need to
we need to practice framing it as a
learning experience every time no matter
yeah no matter how the information comes
to us yeah how soft or how harsh or
however it comes yeah to view it as a
learning experience yeah and if you're
anything like me and hit quite a few
reminders like always in kindergarten
always yeah and that's why we're just so
also like we're so good at actually
seeing each other like where we're late
not accepting or saying yes or turning
away from our best like engagement and
in the past that used to be a problem
because if someone like criticized you
it's like painful and defensive and
you've got to like deal with it but now
we can use that skill to actually help
us grow and we're very good at doing
that you only need to go to a basketball
game to see like the whole crowds doing
that like criticizing the best
basketball players on the planet but the
amount of feed they could but they can
see their weaknesses they can't they
actually can yeah it's amazing
so we finest everyone's like awareness
if they could actually connect yeah but
you don't have to go to your family and
they'll tell you all the places you need
to go yeah no problem this is a very
good point yeah this is a very good
point
at at the same time we can probably
agree that there's quite a high amount
of noise in the critique yeah that's
happening meanwhile there's still signal
and so ones radar for identifying where
that signal is and having mentors that
help them identify that or the show yeah
and which one of the trickiest things is
to like figure out what actually is the
signal like because it doesn't the
critique doesn't necessarily mean that
it's right it could like it could be
that it's right and instead on you have
to open to it or it could be the exact
opposite but like it's calling for you
to say like to set a stronger boundary
or to walk away it's like you could be
calling for completely opposite things
and it's not easy to tell
[Laughter]
see to look at these files that's three
yeah okay what else what else should we
talk about
it's crazy that we are here
what if in the spirit of this if you
were gonna die tonight
what would you have wanted to say now to
reveal just me or civilization yeah just
me die civilization lives on yeah just
update the code update the code maximize
prosperity and I think to month I adore
you mom huh
I got blessed mom yeah what about you
guys
if you were to pass tonight would be
your statement for civilization
I actually the first thing that came to
me was state if I knew that I'm getting
straight on the phone to my fiance I
don't know if I can tell the world
anything better than that
but I certainly would want to be with
her
I feel first love and then gratitude
like
yeah very grateful to experience at all
yes
doesn't it's not a given
grateful to experience at all it's not a
given
so we would just not have any felt
experience that is what would be
happening I mean most of most of the
history of the universe had no felt
experience I don't know I I guess I
don't really know but it seems like most
of the universe even now like what 99.9
- the millionth decimal point percent of
like the actual stuffiness of the
universe as far as we can tell has no
capacity to like know that it's
experiencing at all he so like just to
having it to have a sense of
experiencing it all is like an
unbelievable lottery win yeah
like I got that a lot in this process
with my mother as well just like if one
little thing tiny thing happened I
wouldn't have been conceived yeah like
what an absolute miracle and they're
looking at my brothers and being like
you know in any other second it would
have been someone else or they would
never have been in existence yes it's
like oh what a what a thing to be here
with you and Jordan and these listeners
and damn what a privileged thing it is
to even experience like yeah that's it's
like existence privilege purple
experience privilege I found a lot of
thought something really nice when he
said that yeah
and then on top of that like to be in
this day and age yeah but where we can
talk about it where we can don't know
that it's it's crazy like the amount of
safety and care and love I feel like
we're in encountering like people from
different from every like in not too
long ago I'd be like oh like that
person's probably gonna kill me or my
like family so I ought to kill them
first and not for sure not too long ago
I'm a scale of the cosmic perspective
for sure and yeah now we're having a
live stream conversation with
electricity running water ubiquity and
food it's unbelievable but billions of
people don't have that so just what I
worked you yeah yeah yeah yeah that is
I'm with doing well it seems yeah yeah
the code is good there's a there's a
phrase that we like your time I like
throwing out the obsolete code just
obsoleting it but yeah we have a phrase
in like the integral theory community
yes it's called like transcend and
include yeah of course
that comes from like you know the way
that whatever like molecules transcend
atoms but include them and the rep like
our brains transcend the reptilian brain
stem but includes it and so on and like
we like to joke and like circling Europe
world or like we do transcend and
enhance that's good like that so that's
my offering to ya transcripts it enhance
the code yeah yeah
huh this is crazy
interesting conversation glad we did the
deeper cut because we really got into
some very very pressing and beautiful
conversation yeah
I'm grateful yeah so grateful
yeah however it ended up being that we
were all able to experience this life
and this conversation together with
people that are able to tune in and and
watch share
Oh
I feel like we should do a like a PG
version of the Freestyle please can you
can you do PG not very well not very dry
is that what a rental guy does something
like that yeah yeah it's a it's the
movie rating system but yeah yeah
basically yeah what you'd like a summary
but like Oh like yeah sure I mean if
you'd give me a beat I can try and
summarize our conversation over some
flow what kind of beat just slow slow
beats are good like yeah that was good
yes slow like that we started off
talking about Sean's mom ventured into
time we figured out how slow they can go
if you flow if you let yourself go
but then the clock is ticking yo
so collapse no Barry yo that you want to
go build a future update the code then
we ventured into more kind thoughts we
ended up with the beatbox shot all right
I'll pass it to you no that was good all
right what do you want slow medium fast
it's got to be slow okay keep it yeah
I'm just gonna like hang out as the York
good English guy so just keep going guys
feel the shame in my belly cuz I don't
know what's coming and I'll probably
screw it up yeah what to go run out the
door don't look at me anymore I'm trying
to avoid saying certain words like or
cuz this is PG I guess that's what we
see and don't look at me look at someone
else although I love your attention
cause I'm a big self with the big
capital S and that's the best better
than this little thing that's like
really [ __ ] mess it's so good to be
put on the spot and like have to you
know flow it's so important to freestyle
[Laughter]
we what do you want me to say we bout
your interior arrows here we get some
seen just a little embarrassed now I
probably will regret this for a long
long time
a chance to feel my interior pain I did
want to give a little caveat to what we
were saying we talked about being with
everything as it is and we didn't
mention it that will probably be a lot
of pain and difficult complexity that
will be definitely overwhelming quite
often so good luck with that and I hope
you get the right kind of support
the truth will set you free but there's
no guarantee that it will feel good as
it happens and this is another important
way to to just do freestyle is that you
can do a slow singing this is how we
have our difficult meetings in the
company you do
yeah that's great yeah it's the
interesting strategy I did with my
girlfriend all the time it's amazing the
hard conversations you sing through them
or it not just in hard conversations but
we like to sing to each other on a lake
foam that when I'm away and like just
sometimes comes up so we freeze that and
we were both like people who were scared
of like singing like people must have
seen me late squirming now because late
when I grew up I was like afraid and
felt like it I wasn't okay to you know
express myself and she was somewhat
similar but because we've been singing
together we just get very way more
creative and we connect a lot through
that it's so wonderful and you need to
do this at the company too yeah it was
excellent
it's really great well if there's like
yeah we don't we actually should
probably do it more like if it gets
really tough to like bring it in but
it's more like it happens spontaneously
or it's like I don't know why the hell
you did that it didn't make any sense to
me
could you explain it's quite cold that's
interesting okay because John was a
music musician but we we played with it
before but when he came in he's like
when he circles you he's like is she
like really kind and quite gentle often
but when he's like singing his dark side
comes out so Ruth will set you free
yes thinking about you you get a little
bit of a like like I love the slow sing
that's been another one of the great
free styles yeah I like the application
the two relationships work places that's
really interesting we should do some
more of that one if you're gonna try in
the work whoever I don't even know where
I'm supposed to look at a camera oh we
have come to come to us we'll come to
that one yeah
it's it's good to let go of any sense of
like needing to make a good melody and I
will often sing the same damn melody
yeah like 30 minutes and maybe it will
even be like sometimes we were hanging
out with our friend who's Jewish in New
York so we had this like Jewish melody
and it was like that I it was like the
same note and then it would just go like
one lower and it was just the whole time
like whatever like oh this is gonna be
example okay this is a really bad
example and people would walk around
with us and be like why do you keep
doing this very same song the whole time
yeah this is very good this is very good
information so so we can follow whatever
we choose we can move it around quicker
if we want we can slow it down as well
we can do some up so we can do some
bones so it's I love that I think that's
that's very good let's let's try and do
another one
all right who wants to start us off
Jason if you that cycling oh I have it
I want to do light but you can do dark
if you want feed you this relay let's
take a violin now be fun this has been
such a beautiful time together I love
you both very much and if we can inspire
and engage others maybe they will get a
hunch and maybe they can pursue
something that spiritually actualizes
that
to the unity consciousness we can all
build together
and I can pass it off right now but I
also really want to keep it fun thing to
do to sing it so I'll pass it off to
Jordan now and then he'll pass it off to
Sean but no I am not mowing your lawn
let's go Oh mr. Allen I feel so close to
you quite easily but the same time I
wonder if I can show you all the dark
places in me yeah because I'm afraid
that even though you've got the biggest
enthusiasm in the world that sometimes
when you don't even know it you flinch
and you gently turn away damn let's
unpack this where do I do that [ __ ] here
just drop that I wonder how much you are
on the same wavelength about what'd you
just say
may-maybe we have a different dog all
right so do you sing first or do we
unpack that first we're given packet in
song mr. Islands getting curious now it
doesn't seem like that curiosity which
is just like wow this what is it seems a
little bit more driven what is it what
have you both noticed mr. Island wants
to know what's inside of him he wants to
stay present so he tries pretty pod and
maybe part of him doesn't want to try so
sir moves away to give him some space
for a deeper layer of him he hasn't felt
just quite yet so that little look away
rather than being a problem might be an
opportunity to listen to a deeper
intelligence it's telling him to rest a
little more but not to shame his drive
which is a beautiful expression of his
masculine power and heart sense for a
man in love for everything maybe he
would love to deeply rest at the same
time and be an effortless expression of
all that is
even though he already is that anyway
okay what was it's just the universe
speaking to you as Shawn I have no words
watch the nerve endings of God are you
guys and you're communicating to me
through this and why Mischa you just
forget to include your sound I'm in that
- it's just that you're communicating
from couple nerve endings to me what is
this what are we talking about what is
happening what am i doing that I could
update that to become better please some
out of song it's out of sighs - what a
drive and here crystal I saw you see
part of it just really wants tonight
right sometime but the other part you
just you can tell me will have I would
be resolved update can you feel the part
of you that's afraid if you won't update
something bad might occur
if you feel that part of you right now
it might feel like shame
and if you notice yourself turning your
way don't automatically turn back yeah
what do you mean wait what do you mean I
just I want to unpack this because this
is let's let's talk about it right let's
make it a little bit more clear okay so
what is what what are we what are we
what are we saying here that that me
wanting to to do things and build is has
there's some what it's like inhibiting
some other sort of development that is
important as well well it seems like we
seems like we've like said something
that's late
caught your attention like some and now
you seem like eager like to learn and
let's see what might be happening yeah
more easier to learn and then this drive
to know what we're saying
I said like something like at stake if
you don't well I just I don't I don't
want to not hear what someone's
perspective is on what their thoughts
are on how I engage with reality because
I think it's a very interesting feedback
loop people engage with you they tell
you what their perspective is on how
this is that whole mentor thing that
whole like Tudor thing the whole bloom
to Sigma thing you want to have the
one-on-ones with people that say like
hey consider some of this stuff maybe
it'll help yeah please tell me what you
think that is and so your counter to
that is why do you even worry so much
about what that no no not at all okay
what oh no so you're like please tell me
that's the foreground okay there's a
background that you're not saying it's
implicit in it okay and that's like
that's what we're looking at my guess is
it's something like
I'm afraid I'm missing something and
they're like I'm not and that's gonna be
I don't know painful or harmful or
embarrassing or I just want to level up
right right so yeah I want to level up
that's foreground and then behind that
background is like there's often a
feeling of like I'm not like this level
isn't good enough
what what hap I don't know that's this
level isn't good enough but that's
interesting analysis I don't know if
it's actually that yeah I think it's
just more that I want to level off yeah
and what happens this we sort of
question now and in quiet is it
feel easy or something no I mean I had
those experiences with mentors where I
was like [ __ ] bawling because I was
like looking at myself in the mirror and
being like holy [ __ ]
like I'm ego driven greed driven blah
blah blah blah and I'm just like [ __ ]
like I have to really look at myself in
the mirror and grow and and be more
selfless and wear less ego driven and
more loving and caring and respectful as
greedy bla bla bla bla and so like
anyway this is so far this is like not
as hard compared to that but we just
like white like can you like it just
feels like I'm being teased can you just
tell me what the point is like that I
can do like what are the what is the
thing you're saying I think I I am what
is it that the thing in you that wants
to know the point is very likely being
driven by a sense of inadequacy or
something else that I don't think you're
conscious of why does it have to be in
adequacy I don't it doesn't have to be
it's a question for you why can't it
just be a desire to level up it could be
okay so then I doubt it is why just from
my experience of like being in this
inquiry with a shitload of people over
the next like ten years and my own
experience okay so but why does it have
to why has it been having to come from
people from a place of inadequacy like I
view this as a game I view this as
levelling up I view this as gaining
experience points right and if I've
really been pushing myself in that
paradigm for a while it does kind of
make sense that it's just like like like
I hope that you share this wisdom with
me so that I can level up not not that
I'm inadequate well what would be bad
about that like why is that why would
that be a bad thing to have that
the drive well I don't necessarily think
that it's a bad thing for that to be the
drive it's just more than yeah
it is more so that I mean I would need
to like continue analyzing myself and
seeing like how this comes up and
whatnot but it definitely to me does not
seem like that at least not right now
and like basically if I'm not
so just by engage with people and
they're not willing to like to like help
me level up like I'm not going to engage
with them like that's just how I have
figured out how to flow because like
this conversation is so much levelling
up and like it feels amazing but at the
same time like I know that like if I'm
having conversation with people here and
it's just like you know first of all it
wouldn't happen like they won't come on
to the show but that if it's like out on
the street or whatever and it's like
there's just nothing is coming up at
that time I'm like I can't contribute
anymore I gotta go yeah that's it and
like I can find this potentially from
other places but I'm not like maybe it
has been inadequacy for people that
you've chatted with but there's like a
myriad a plethora of different options
of what this could potentially be so I
think I'm with you I don't know like I
don't know if there's more to this or
like the only thing I'm sensing that
as we've gone into this inquiry about
like something we're potentially seeing
I
I actually feel like maybe for the first
time like we're not in a shared yeah
yeah and and that's okay
yeah greed but it there's I think
there's like I feel very careful being
on camera as well like why for your
sacrum Isaac for me yeah yeah
yeah like it like some ways I'm like
struggling to know how to connect with
you here well I'm still curious what the
piece of advice is like it's been five
minutes since we started talking about
this piece of advice that you were
singing and I didn't understand it it
wasn't intended to be advice or whatever
it was intended to be like it's just
like I just I just I'm interested to
know what it was this thing that you
were singing and how did is it
potentially apply to my life and like I
still haven't heard it and we've spent
the whole time talking about well what
is it that you're like seeking this
information for and I'm like I want to
level up like is this worth my time like
that will you tell me what this is
you let working out if you can trust
like that we have something where the
way just play and no I just want to know
what it is
that I can try okay well I space like
one thing is like I I'm not sure like
the way that you're asking for the
advice is like coming from like a place
where you can listen this is wait this
is that's the first bit okay yeah that
that I'm positioning myself in a way
that is less receptive to the advice I
don't think you're not intentionally my
sense is you deeply care about this this
I mean it really matters to you about
leveling up too and I don't in any way
want to shame that because I don't I
like it or I trust it okay and there's
something that just has me a little
uneasy in it like I know this look
sometimes when you're expressing it I
actually feel like a little empty or I'm
like I find myself waiting for the end
of the sentence because like and I don't
know why that is like it might not be
because you're doing anything but I
certainly know this
Hey
I know what happens in me like I stop
yeah I just start to wait so I don't
feel on the train with you sometimes in
that drive so that does give me a
hypothesis that maybe there's more to be
expressed
in that drive than you they need okay
fine let's put it this way
I barely know myself okay
I barely know myself I barely know how I
interplay with this world right I barely
know these things if I quote this
forever kindergarten thing and then I'm
like I have it all figured out you know
then that's like two completely
different perspectives so I'm in
perpetual kindergarten I don't know
myself or my subconscious or my
unconscious that well I barely know my
conscious that well and the way I
interact with reality so if you're to
hypothesize that this is coming
potentially from place inadequacy or
whatever other millions of adjectives
could potentially exist in that scenario
sure I'm open to it so yeah here's
another way to say it then so that you
know you know how like I think you'll
you like you and your viewers will get
this like people were like they're
driving to get like achievement or build
the hierarchy or whatever sure earn a
ton of money and then like one day
they're like wait what is this for like
this is for happiness or well-being or
health or something and they like kind
of they're like wow this whole thing was
for some other thing that's like more
important and they set aside they're
like I don't need to do money I just
want to be well and and be okay like you
could like you could watch like Jim
Carrey went through this transfer sure
sure yeah and then you go through that
for a while and you're like man
happiness and health and well-being this
is all super important you're driving
for that it's and then suddenly you're
like hold on what's the point of that
like who cares if I'm happy if I'm not
like doing something meaningful for the
world
yeah like update the code make an impact
or yeah help people and so then you
realize I all of that was to try to get
you to a place where you could do this
yes this this layer I think that
developmental sequence keeps going yes
and like it's very hard to see the thing
and I think what we're pointing to is
that this layer itself I think is what
you're like operating from
long time as often as possible yeah and
so like
this I think underneath the same way
they like underneath this achievement
like there's some like often like
something else driving it or underneath
this need for happiness or health or
well-being is like an unhappiness or an
unhealthy ran unwellness that often
comes from the previous stage there's
like under this drive for like growing
or leveling up there's often a kind of
pain and existential pain almost like
does my life have meaning and purpose
like I'm not sure like cuz I'm actually
pretty [ __ ] small in the grand scheme
of the cosmos and I don't know even if I
like improved humanity in a massive way
for the next 10,000 years I don't know
that my life actually has that much
meaning and that's a really scary thing
to look at when you're a self-identity
and the advice that I haven't given you
that now I'm gonna give is it like is it
that's worth turning to look at it's
hard to do it but it's like that's and
ironically that's the thing that I think
will level you up the most it's like to
keep facing the sense of like my like
the limitation of my small self for my
ego or my drive for for permanence we
started this whole thing with
impermanence like that the irony is that
when I'm willing to continuously face
that and the pain of that and like the
inadequacy of that and then not enough
Nisour that what it does is eventually I
become identified with something that's
so much bigger in this small self so it
almost like pops me out into something
vast and and permanent but not in a
sense of mind like Jordan itself but in
the sense of like
the universe itself being permanent even
though it's in constant change in
constant expansion
and like if if I could bring like that
would be that's the biggest joy for me
it's to like I'm like yeah it's gonna
suck the development or the truth
doesn't always feel good but like if if
I could open that to you or even like
plant a seed which I hope we've done
tonight that's like the best thing I
could possibly give you in my whole life
yeah I think I'm following this the
reflection so that this pursuit of
wanting to update code is in itself a
you get to pick which one which one ego
or transcendent experience and the more
that I gravitate towards transcendent
experience of this is coming through me
into civilization don't put my name on
[ __ ] just [ __ ] build it go unity
we're good to go
[Laughter]
like monied to be that these analogies
and metaphors and synthesis of all that
is that's happening gets stamped with my
[ __ ] impermanent ass name on [ __ ]
more so why doesn't the beauty of the
analogy metaphor synthesis of all that
is actually act as a seed in itself and
letting thousands of other people go and
build on top of it that makes it so much
better and then I'm just like I'm gone
so that's the point and it's good to
hear this from you because it helps me
continuously go you know double-check
yeah okay okay double check okay okay
keep triple quadruple quintuple keep
going keep checking
keep checking check through your whole
life ego or transcendence ego or
transcendence or like however you know
we want to phrase that but
I'm still little in the energy which
felt very good I hope it felt good to
receive or but lucky there's there's
still a challenge like when you say that
I'm like yeah the pointer to like to the
the other thing is like building isn't
always the thing well depends on how
much you want to build this is the thing
but I'm saying it I don't want it to
depend on how much you want to build I
want it to depend on like what what God
wants Allen to be like doing in the
world which maybe not building yet
tearing down which Bay maybe neither but
like being an amazing interviewer it may
be some other thing may be that you
actually find yourself like the the
biggest gift you could give the world
and a kind of like sensitive dependence
chaos theory butterfly wing thing is
like to go like or even like the kind of
Lao Tzu
like he was the legend is that he's like
walking out of China or wherever it was
I'm sorry to everyone whose culture I'm
butchering right now but he's like
walking out at the country and and the
guards like he's so wise like you need
to like at least leave us with a piece
of writing he's like fine he like goes
back and like writes for three days in
the heads of the thing and he's out and
he's like he has no he has no idea he's
not trying to change the world he's not
trying to build in fact he's like I
guess I should write some stuff and it's
like one of the deepest books of wisdom
that the human species has okay and you
can't know that and you can't predict
that and you can't want that how we
doing
yeah this is fantastic having a great
time learning about this from you guys I
am I'm having a great time I think
patience has helped a lot for me that's
helped a lot it used to be like a couple
even like a year and
little more ago it used to be like how
can I get this done as soon as possible
and then it was like just be patient and
now it's been like I love being patient
because the synthesis just keeps getting
stronger and stronger and of course I
would prefer to not just walk with the
synthesis out and be done like I would
much rather figure out ways to
disseminate the synthesis to inspire and
engage people to realize that holy [ __ ]
there's a big massive potential of code
updates that we can do and so like what
do you want do you want to do you want
to start do you want to do you want to
start an organization that impacts one
person ten people a hundred people a
million people ten million people how
many people do you want to impact the
organization if you don't offer yourself
some sort of a future that you want
you'll just be kind of like and I have I
have a you know conscientiousness is the
second measure of intelligence most
robust measure after IQ and conscious
and for that exact reason that the most
conscientious people are the ones that
are able to say that's my goal that's
where I find meaning in life I'm going
to take steps in a month I'm gonna be
here in ten I'm gonna be there in three
years I'm gonna be there and that if it
doesn't this is the thing if there's
flexibility Dadi trunky you'll calm and
flexibility along this whole path so
it's not saying I'm forcing it it's
saying that I'm totally flexible and
calm along the journey but I have goals
and it's not about this leaving
something that updates the code of
civilization forever and I get to be a
sage on the stage it's way more about
can this past The Linde effect can you
create something as profound as the
wheel whereas profound as language can
you do that because if you do you will
make such great updates to the way that
people live in this
world it will maximize flourishing
faster and that's a goal that I have and
flexibility tranquille get there great
don't no worries get to five people
great get to five million people awesome
that's how I feel about it
does that help but yeah it's eight seems
clear seems like we we're almost say
it's almost the same mission or the
space way like turning towards like
what has this want to grow and build a
which we have very strong and night like
trying to get more information from that
place in US and and then I don't know
where that's going to lead us like
whether we should be like you know how
big we should be or whatever late I'll
do my best
they show up and be truthful but maybe
our wheel is this process of turning
towards and being in connection around
it and transforming relationships
through it's like deep grappling with a
actualization but also our existential
or spiritual pain fears including that
range in connection
first I think there's like similar but
just slight difference it's gonna be
exciting to see how that plays out does
it does that resonate I'm trying to
understand that so it seems like we're
coming from potentially a very similar
first principle but then there's some
sort of a difference between I think so
okay yeah but that this sense of like
when you say about like creating a wheel
like both creating an innovation that
makes a difference like certainly feel
that was circling and surrender
leadership I feel alive and proudness
that this like method came through us
like sincerely practicing but also like
you know working very hard and so
there's a proudness about that but then
I think it's just quite scary to know
like really what it's all for and if I'm
really aligned and if I really can make
a difference those I think they just
find that a rich place to explore as
well why do you feel that way why do you
feel like it's a good question because I
think if maybe it might be that the
level of comfortability you have with
how much time you're in putting on
building something that you find to be
meaningful and important and it's per a
tional for other people that maybe there
is some sort of a like it's like it's
got to be cool if it just hits five
people you know
I I think if I'm really honest I I think
I would have have to meet a lot of pain
if it works out that we shrink to that
size but but in but if life is if that's
the lesson I need to learn because I try
I'm certainly like got this like
ambition that comes through me yeah it
doesn't even seem like it's going that
way anyway but yeah but if but if if
somehow we like full you know down I
imagine that's going to be a very hard
process but then I feel willing is the
best I can to if that's what it's meant
to be this is an interesting into the
conversation I didn't think we were
going to eat here after freestyling it's
very funny see ya soon as we touch
something important they think I've been
able to put my finger quite on it yet no
me too I'm forever in kindergarten but I
think we started somehow getting to it
maybe it does seem like it has to do
with whatever your ultimate calling is
to build that with full intention to
bring it at whatever scale it ends up
coming and having that be a transcendent
experience rather than a ego driven one
yeah I think I'm gonna make an even
stronger claim okay and but before I do
the theoretical claim I just want to
like acknowledge your honor that like
the drive to like impact a lot of
people's very strong in me for sure and
in us and like we just opened this
circling studio in Austin this circling
every day and that the tagline is like a
gym for emotional health it's great this
is it's a good one thanks yeah yeah and
the idea is to bring in more like a it's
more mainstream so people can come do a
workout and then they go off and do the
rest of the day they don't have to be
into like transformational communication
or meditation or anything like that I'm
just like oh yeah that seems good I need
I need
- I need to get a little bit more of
that like a tune-up or go every week and
that's great
so like that's I'm inspired by that the
potential of like this could actually be
very helpful for a lot of people in a
wide-scale and I'm gonna keep acting in
those directions that said there's
something I think if we get too attached
to like our sense of what our actions
are it's I get this a lot when I come to
San Francisco and Silicon Valley we're
like yeah I'm gonna change the world or
make a big difference even if it's not
about me and I'm like I'm not gonna have
my name on it there's something about
like you know my actions or my life is
yoked to like making a huge difference
sure I think often that actually keeps
one from making the difference that they
could make because they're so loose and
they're driven towards a particular
agenda they're actually not very good at
listening to other data that comes from
other streams that might direct them in
another way okay fair enough but what
about manifesting the future that you
want through thought so I that's it we
can we can go into that it's a different
topic but I think it's the same topic
it's the same topic I think you're right
about these edge cases if you're so
obsessed with this path and you're
hearing data from over here and you're
not listening and that could actually
help you you're missing stuff I don't
think they're edge cases I think if you
look at like you know Steve Jobs getting
kicked out of Apple like and having to
go off and do all this other stuff I
think if you look you're like Richard
Fineman won the Nobel Prize because he
like got excited about like spinning
plates of a waiter not because he was
like trying to create nobel
prize-winning physics I think we could L
know any famous person that changed the
course of history if we looked back at
like I mean there's there's gonna be a
few exceptions but like most of them was
like an accident that made sense when
you look back at it not because they
like thought of what they wanted to do a
back
I don't know if he I don't know if you'd
say could use the word most in that
scenario but yeah you're probably right
yeah yeah yeah but a lot this is an
interesting point there are likely some
people that saw something that said see
a bird make a plane and that could have
been their inspiration it maybe didn't
start just as make a plane okay yeah
could have been something else whatever
it was that created the stimuli for them
to change the world
sure does conscientiousness and
goal-setting have something to do with
it yes
does manifesting the reality with
thought being creation does that have
something to do with it
probably yes does being so driven
towards this one path to get there that
you don't actually list here or see or
listen to nature or you hear meditation
or mindfulness spirituality anything
else
friends family nature along the way yes
these things all compound together to
this story and and one has to just you
know feel out what that is and I'm
extremely open-minded and I'm already
learning a lot from the way that you
guys are teaching me about this
specifics on your views and perspectives
on this it's just interesting to me that
you may feel that I am like like going
in some direction that you guys are like
yo are you like you know I know what
yeah well I felt like we're in a totally
different part of the conversation it's
less it's not doesn't feel directed at
you anymore agreed but then it only came
up because as I said it came up in the
song and I don't even know how it came
up in the song I was like no I mean like
how did it come up like how did you guys
go like together I think we're just like
something John said he he saw he
yeah when I when I said something
emotional right in the first call we had
the first video you you went like that
and then gave a third-person perspective
and then he was like ugh but what did it
feel like when I said I felt warm so in
that movement it was like oh yeah maybe
something happened there that's kind of
cool like a micro message so then in the
song we're just saying that oh maybe
beast on that maybe that move yeah it's
that subtle and we don't know but ears
but I wasn't so you so I said I said
that when you did that maybe the part of
you that wants to relax expresses itself
in ways you don't know yet sometimes
you know I I know I was just like
throwing out playfully and obviously I
was like a little bit late
hypothesizing a little but not that
seriously but it's obviously caught some
fire so then we've been looking saying
okay and my sense of the way we got was
like
imagine on your side it's like look I
really want to make a difference I know
what happens if you fall asleep at the
wheel there are things that make a
difference I've seen it I've experienced
it you make some real difference okay
and and then the thing I was trying not
to do that's what it was hard was to say
no to that because I actually agree with
it but I was just like saying that in my
experience in my growth what's actually
been really compelling is actually late
like while actually continuing to like
try to grow the best they can getting
curious about like in more subtle layers
oh yeah what is it that drives me
actually and it's not ego in a like
small egocentric sense but it's just
like it's just that oh yeah what is
creating the self in me that drives to
grow okay and I was my hypothesis we
could explore that and it would there
would be fruitful like like bindings I
agree if we did it with all of us of
course and in in that I don't think it
would tell you I'm imagining wouldn't
tell you too late stop like creating the
stuff you're doing Roy I imagine it
would like show you a map of a more
complex way to do it that would also be
more lifeforce excellent safe so I
thought we were together that was just
like this like little Swiss and and this
is where we're working like we're
working with that kind of circle team
you guys have after your whatever tens
of thousands of circles and yeah it's
just crazy that that you can identify
something as miniscule as that as that
responsible I have to go and look back
and find it because it I don't even
remember and sometimes maybe these
readings are like something about them
that they did that maybe didn't actually
have to do with that subconscious
thought process but for sure but that's
also very interesting to even unpack in
the first place of what okay why why why
why go deeper and deeper into why why
why why why and then maybe you'll find
something that that lives there I want
to make two I think I spoke falsely you
know I wanna up
okay first of all I have no idea what I
might actually probably we can't get in
the way of whatever the like what I said
like God's plan for us is like whether
we want to or not we probably can't and
like the example I think of is like the
the bacteria that like lived and died
and then they're like 200 million years
of like billions of bacteria living and
dying created the ozone layer which
created the like structure for all of
life on earth to emerge like it didn't
matter whether they tried to create the
ozone layer or not like they were gonna
do it so that like that at that scale
it's really like whether we try or not
like you know we're gonna we're gonna do
the things we're meant to do
so I think I was wrong 10 minutes ago
like whenever I made some claims that
maybe you're yeah maybe it wasn't maybe
I just wasn't that I could be a lot more
accurate more precise and then I'm just
sorry about that I welcome your your new
update it's here point I'm sure that I
have plenty of those as well if you're
looking back like to the first episodes
of the show there's so many times I'm
like oh my gosh yeah I'm gonna that's so
funny yeah I'm trying to practice like
really when I noticed where those things
really coming forward and being like
yeah I was totally mistaken and like
really making an effort to like show
that and face the kind of because I I
can notice my internal like flinching
away from not wanting to be seen and
just immediately saying oh yeah now good
the new one it's cool well let's let's
talk about this I think I think it's
very funny because people will
there's two funny things here one funny
thing is that we don't go why why why
why why down to like the depths of the
course of people in the first place that
often but then to is if you've already
done this practice with mentors and
friends which I have in this case and
likely you guys and lots of other people
out circle have a lot gone down to the
Y's the deepest why's the the things
that come up are usually things about
selfishness things about money power
Fame clout influence genetic fitness to
get a better mate just all of those
things some of those things mmm in some
percentages whatever and then there's
people that have spent so much time
analyzing those and digging into
themselves to try and figure out what is
it what is it art is it any of those
kind look at myself in the mirror is at
that okay well I did get called out okay
I got called out I need to work on my
okay cool I'm worked on it now that's
less coming up awesome
so then what then what you've worked on
this these things aren't as existent as
maybe they once were and then you're
prioritizing thought is creation you're
prioritizing this is about world peace
this is about transcending my own ego
this is about leaving behind a better
civilization for five ten a million
people whatever it is you start
embodying these things you start
practicing it so that every single time
that you are at the end of the month
have just a couple extra hundred dollars
in your account that you immediately
give that money to the people that have
helped support you to get to the point
that you're at and you're back at zero
and then you like do it again it's just
like you start doing processes that just
completely change you'll by
materialistic [ __ ] you you just you you
just you behave thank you so soon you
this is vegan
that there is this this is why why why
why why okay I've identified them I'm
working on some of them but mostly it's
these it seems like you you've got a
concern if there is this like looking at
the subtleties and then like diving
deeper that like you could do that
process to such an extent actually you
wouldn't be creating all the things
they're actually making a difference is
that the concern oh I would say it's
more about how it's like these types of
conversations happen now often more
often which is excellent that they even
happen more often but then you get to
this point where it's like it's like the
simulation has to get to the point where
you're experiencing it so that you can
actually make the decision about if it's
ego or transcendence and then so like
how do you level yourself up to get at
that point and then you're faced with
the example and then you collapse into
the direction that you've built yourself
up to and so and so it's just like I've
worked on this I'm gonna keep working on
it and like I'm just gonna have to get
to those moments these bifurcations of
is it about Igor is it about
transcendence you get the opportunity to
write your [ __ ] name on something are
you gonna choose to write your name on
it or are you gonna choose to say this
isn't about me
and is there furthermore is there an
argument that can be made for the last
names on the hospitals and the schools
and on all the blah blahs of the world
is there an argument to be made could it
be that if you have made that much money
maybe it's actually about showing other
people that people that make that much
money should give back to hospitals and
schools because there's nuance and the
branding of a name on something isn't
necessarily 100% binary about ego
so there's tons of nuance totally so if
someone chooses to write a book and they
choose to anonymize it so that their
name isn't on it like blockchain Satoshi
Nakamoto right excellent but if someone
chooses to make a profound innovation
and then chooses to say yeah that was me
I made it and like I'm happy to tour
schools and talk about it and stuff is
that so there's all this nuance here and
so I'm not necessarily this is just this
is interesting that we got to this point
because it's cool I'm just I'm not
necessarily I just like build up the
skills work with the people like what is
happening right now and get to the point
where these decisions have to be made
between ego or transcendence or however
you want to view it and you know see how
you behave and keep working on yourself
like I think to wrap up for me like I
feel with you on this sense of like I've
definitely historically and maybe still
am like a deep diver like being about
like I want to know my relationship to
existence I want to discover the deeper
States and the deeper feelings I have
about the world about myself I've always
been that way even though I've also been
pretty action orientated as well but
but recently there's been a shift that's
happening in me that's it's late
something like it's not
it's not about deeper or
that there's nothing to find other than
what's already presenting itself
and and so a circle for me now late has
is no longer about like will I find the
that the states or the pain or the
whatever the vote of the belief system
that I can deconstruct so then get to
the late promised you know to so then I
can be in the world it's it's more like
a discovery like I don't know what's
going to present itself
and it it could just be a mental like a
thought that inspires me or like someone
seeing me that touches me and gives me
confidence to do the thing that I
haven't done yet or so it seems again
we're we're like playing in a similar
field
navigating the same problems
and hopefully supporting each other if
we can and I feel that yeah with you
and I have to go to sleep I just I do
when I came start trying to synthesize
and make a knowledge graph of this whole
conversation so much stuff it was a bit
of a beast it was a it was a beast this
would be a fun one to try and make a
knowledge graph of we're excited to get
to that point with the series where we
can make knowledge graphs of the
conversation transcripts parse four key
points all this cool stuff that were
working on yeah yeah it was interesting
starting with your mother and then
leading us into time and then getting us
somehow to where we started talking
about what lies at these deepest why's
this is really good stuff
via beatboxing oh there was a beatbox in
the middle as a whole like what and then
Jordan would stop singing that was funny
yeah a lot that was a lot of fun we must
we must continue you know a little
tradition of having the recording studio
be open for for this when you guys are
around so yes me : and we'll make it
happen keep it going
thank you thanks for having us and just
doing thanks for being the unique person
that you are that's driven to level up
and and help level others up and create
this in a way that is having impact some
people in really positive ways you yeah
YouTube would sir really thanks man
yeah we have so much distilled
go create yeah
yeah I can't believe you guys didn't
notice some microexpression that
triggered all that other stuff like I'm
like what like how do I get yeah yeah
sure after practicing so many of those
micro expressions you can get - yeah I
think we've done a 10,000 hours yeah
yeah for mastery for sure for sure
that's where yeah we're going with being
an interlocutor and hosting a show as
well yeah one thing I do know is that I
am pursuing code updates a synthesis of
all that is into analogies and metaphors
that are extremely relatable that
obsolete the old code what you say
transcend and enhance enhance transcend
and enhance civilization so and so
hopefully more people can figure out
what that divine calling is and pursue
it conscientiously being flexible anyway
all right let's call it so thanks
everyone thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it where you just
had a little love sign forever
thank you huge thank you for sticking
with us through what has been a very
interesting and so many epic point
episode do check out you know obviously
it's been the deeper cut so do check out
the previous episode of Jordan and Sean
on transformational communication that
was the previous episode check that out
and check out the links below to their
projects circling Europe calm as well as
their online every day circling circle
anywhere calm and surrender leadership
surrendered leadership calm so check
those out everyone and support
simulation support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe in support
simulation so we continue growing and
scaling and everything our links are
below and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much everyone thank you so much for
tuning in to share more awesome content
and aspects of the conversation like we
had today with more people around the
world and we'll see you soon everyone
peace